langsam dürfte sich herumgesprochen
haben am 26 september ist wahltag zehn
stunden lang können die leute in ganz
deutschland bei der bundestagswahl ihre
stimme abgeben pünktlich um 18 uhr
schließen die wahllokale dann in den
parteizentralen auf den wahlpartys
schauen viele gebannt auf die
bildschirme denn nach ende der
stimmabgabe kommt die 18 uhr prognose
das erste mal sehen wir zahlen zum
möglichen wahlergebnis aber wie kann das
sein wenn die auszählung noch gar nicht
begonnen hat was ist das überhaupt für
eine prognose wie kommt sie zustande was
ist der unterschied zu den
hochrechnungen die im laufe des abends
folgen genau das erklären wir euch jetzt
[Musik]
fangen wir um die prognose zu verstehen
weil ein stückchen früher an als 18 uhr
am wahltag schon wochen vor der wahl
gibt es im politbarometer ja immer die
zahlen der sogenannten projektion
da geht es um die frage welche partei
würden sie wählen wenn am sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre da wird eine
repräsentative wählergruppe befragt wen
sie wählen würden und zwar am telefon
wie genau die telefonbefragungen
ablaufen das sagen bei euch schon mal
erklärt in einem anderen video das
findet ihr wenn ihr oben auf das klingt
die projektion ist deshalb etwas ganz
anderes als die prognose am wahltag
könnt ihr schon wieder vergessen
lohnt sich natürlich zu wissen logisch
im gegensatz zur umfrage im vorfeld der
wahl entstehen die daten für die
prognose bei sogenannten exit-polls am
wahltag gibt es nämlich nicht nur die
offizielle abstimmung sondern in rund
400 wahllokalen die zufällig ausgewählt
wurden überall in deutschland stehen
korrespondenten der forschungsgruppe
wahlen dieses jahr werden 1000
interviewerinnen und interviewer dafür
eingesetzt und die bitten die besucher
der wahllokale dann ein zweites mal
abzustimmen rund 40.000 werden befragt
und werfen ihren zusätzlichen
stimmzettel dann in die urne des
meinungsforschungsinstituts und apropos
wahlurnen wusstet ihr eigentlich dass
bei manchen wahlen in deutschland auch
mülltonnen als warnung eingesetzt werden
das soll günstig seien und die sind gut
zu bewegen mit den rädern finden
allerdings nicht alle gut dann irgendwie
könnte das ja auch das bild vermitteln
die stimmen seien die tonne das aber nur
am rande jetzt zurück zur abstimmung der
forschungsgruppe wahlen da wird nach der
wahl nicht nur abgefragt was die leute
gewählt haben sondern es geht auch um
soziale merkmale wie geschlecht alter
beruf warum ist das wichtig naja damit
die ergebnisse entsprechend gewichtet
werden können oder man sagt auch
korrigiert nicht manipuliert das meinen
auch einige aber dazu kommen wir später
noch mal die offiziellen wahlurnen
bleiben bis 18 uhr geschlossen die
stimmzettel der befragung werden dagegen
stündlich ausgewertet wenn es aber schon
den ganzen tag über befragungen gibt
darum kommt die prognose dann erst um 18
uhr theoretisch könnten die
meinungsforscher ihre teilergebnisse ja
über den tag verteilt veröffentlichen
und immer wieder ein update geben die
könnten dann aber ziemlich verzerrt sein
den blick in die statistik ist nämlich
ganz spannend anhänger der union gehen
beispielsweise gerne schon morgens zur
stimmabgabe die wählerschaft der grünen
schafft es meistens erst gegen abend und
um solche schwankungen über den tag
auszugleichen wartet die
forschungsgruppe wahlen ab bis 18 uhr
bis dann die wahllokale auch tatsächlich
geschlossen sind dann gibt es die
prognose dass gemittelte ergebnis zeigt
dann ein repräsentatives bild und es
kann die leute die ihre stimme erst noch
abgeben auch nicht beeinflussen weil man
ja seine stimme nicht mehr abgeben kann
nach 18 uhr aber wie wird dieses
spannende geheimnisse der
zwischenergebnisse dann bewahrt da gibt
es ja schon einige leute die bescheid
wissen zunächst mal sind wir gesetzlich
verpflichtet keine ergebnisse vor
schließung der wahllokale aus den
befragungen veröffentlichen und schon
allein deshalb müssen wir da großen wert
darauf legen geheim halten kann man am
besten etwas mit dem man ist einfach
niemanden erzählt die geheimhaltung ist
aber nicht die einzige schwierigkeit bei
der prognose die teilnahme an der
zusätzlichen befragung ist freiwillig
das heißt nicht jeder wähler der
wahllokal seine stimme abgibt taucht
auch in der prognose auf es gibt
menschen die nicht mitmachen wollen oder
die falsche dinge angeben zu diesem
problem haben auch schon mal ein video
gemacht das findet ihr logischerweise
oben auf den damit die prognose
möglichst nahe an das spätere amtliche
ergebnis kommt müsste die
teilnahmebereitschaft eine befragung der
forschungsgruppe wahlen in den
verschiedenen wählergruppen gleich sein
doch mal als beispiel wenn liberale
wähler eher an der befragung teil neben
und konservative weniger zum beispiel
dann könnte das das ergebnis der
prognose verfälschen ebenfalls ein
problem in den wahllokalen wird nur
befragt wer da ist logisch dass schließt
dann aber alle bürgerinnen und bürger
aus die per briefwahl ihre stimme
abgeben und die werden von wahl zu wahl
mehr vor allem der in einer pandemie
außerdem ist es so dass statistisch
gesehen anhänger einiger parteien er per
briefwahl abstimmen als die anderer
parteien auch hier müssen weitere
faktoren berücksichtigt werden zb auch
viele junge menschen die bei per post
abstimmen dann läge die altersstruktur
der prognose daneben die ergebnisse der
befragung vor ort müssen deshalb nach
einem bestimmten system korrigiert
werden und wie genau funktioniert ist
diese korrektur von der wir schon
mehrfach gesprochen haben wir haben zum
beispiel einen deutlichen zusammenhang
zwischen der formalen bildung der
wählerinnen und wähler
und der teilnahme das heißt je höher der
bildungsgrad ist desto stärker
und je älter die menschen sind desto
häufiger nehmen sie auch an der
briefwahl teil es gibt über ein neues in
der briefwahl und den müssen wir
entsprechend dem anteil der briefwähler
dann auch nochmal korrigierend zu den
ergebnissen hinzufügen die wir in der
befragung vor den wahllokalen am sonntag
ermitteln das heißt also dass
korrigierte ergebnis der prognose ist
eine annäherung an das wahlergebnis aber
die genau schafft die forschungsgruppe
war das eigentlich schauen wir uns dazu
mal die zahlen der letzten
bundestagswahl an das ist also der stand
um 8.10 uhr aus den daten der
zusätzlichen befragung das vorläufige
endergebnis der bundestagswahl war dann
dass die abweichung zwischen prognose
und wahlergebnis liegt zwischen 0,1
prozentpunkten bei den grünen das ist
also schon fast exakt und 0,7 bei der
fdp und bei den bundestagswahlen 2013
und 2009 sah es ähnlich aus ist
statistisch betrachtet noch ein
korrektes ergebnis kann man sich darauf
verlassen also zum glück haben wir noch
nie bei uns komplett verschätzt wenn wir
jetzt im rahmen der statistische fehler
ist jetzt sehen das problem ist immer
dass das die laufe des wahlabends die
auszählung der briefwahl lokale viel
später kommt als die das heißt also die
schwächste der schwächste bestandteil
unserer prognose nämlich die abschätzung
des briefwahl effekt der wird auch durch
faktische daten erst relativ spät am
wahlabend
unterstützt oder geklärt und dadurch
bleibt eine gewisse rest unsicherheit
auch noch für spätere hochrechnung dann
erhalten die prognose kommt also schon
ziemlich genau an das spätere ergebnis
heran aber sie beruht auf zusätzlich
erhobenen daten als annäherung und nicht
auf den eigentlichen stimmzetteln anders
sieht das bei den hochrechnungen aus die
ersten echten zahlen also die die sich
aus den gezählten stimmzettel ergeben
kommen etwas später als die prognose bei
der letzten bundestagswahl war das schon
um 18 13 der fall die beobachter der
forschungsgruppe wahlen die an den
zufällig ausgewählten wahllokalen sind
haben nämlich noch eine aufgabe sie
melden die zwischenstände der amtlichen
auszählung umgehend dem
meinungsforschungsinstitut diese
ergebnisse werden dann für ganz
deutschland hochgerechnet eben das
bedeutet die forschungsgruppe wahlen
schließt von den auszählungen der rund
400 befragungs orte auf das
gesamtergebnis
aber wie wird denn dann genau
hochgerechnet und was ist mit den
briefwählern wir haben diese
auszeichnung natürlich zunächst mal bei
den wahllokalen die in dem die menschen
direkt wählen und dazu kommen dann eben
halt auch noch stimmen aus der briefwahl
diese stimmen aus der briefwahl werden
in gesonderten briefen stimmbezirken
ausgezählt und die kommen in der regel
etwas später noch hinzu so dass wir
zunächst mal für die hochrechnung damit
erfahrungswerten uns aushelfen müssen um
die verzerrung die in der vergangenheit
auch durch die briefwahl noch mal
entstanden ist entsprechend zu
berücksichtigen die hochrechnungen
werden im laufe des abends immer wieder
aktualisiert wenn neue amtliche
teilergebnisse feststehen je mehr
stimmen ausgezählt werden desto mehr
nähern sich die ergebnisse der
hochrechnung an das tatsächliche
endergebnis an bis das fest steht also
zumindest das vorläufige amtliche
endergebnis dauert es aber eine weile in
der regel wird es spät in der nacht oder
am nächsten morgen bekannt gegeben das
vorläufige endergebnis der wahl 2017 gab
es morgens um 5 uhr 30 also falls ihr
bis dahin wach bleiben wollt dann stellt
euch da auf ein das ist länger dauern
könnte was denkt ihr denn ergibt es sinn
am wahlabend auf die 18 uhr prognose hin
zu fiebern bleibt ihr wach oder
interessiert euch das alles gar nicht
schreibt gerne unten in die kommentare
und wenn euch dieses video hier gefallen
hat dann geht uns gerne ein like würde
uns freuen ansonsten findet ihr hier
noch eine playlist die das team von zdf
heute für euch zusammengestellt hat rund
um die bundestagswahl
da unbedingt mal reinschauen und hier
einst von unserer kleinen reihe
politbarometer to go warum wahl umfragen
vor der wahl nicht immer mit dem
ergebnis am ende übereinstimmen in der
vergangenheit vor allem bei der afg zu
beobachten vielen dank fürs zuschauen
und bis zum nächsten mal